bonsoir pierre vous êtes donc devant
cette assemblée nationale où les députés
sont à l'intérieur mais à des parisiens
et peut-être d'autres français se sont
donné rendez-vous justement pour
protester contre l' usage du 49-3 par le
gouvernement
effectivement un magali vous venez de le
dire plusieurs centaines voire même
peut-être plusieurs milliers de français
se sont réunis ce soir devant à
l'assemblée nationale un plusieurs
personnes qui se sont rassemblées dès 18
heures pour protester contre l' annonce
du premier ministre edouard philippe
quant à l'application de cet article 49
3 nous avons rencontré un plusieurs de
ces manifestants tout au long de cette
soirée je vous propose justement d'en
écouter certains d'entre eux est une
façon d'empêcher le débat de changer de
la question posée est donc c'est
vraiment un coup d'état politique qui
est extrêmement grave mais nous sommes
en lien avec plusieurs groupes
parlementaires nous sommes des
syndicalistes en nous faisant un lien
entre nous la différence en directions
syndicales cgt fo solidaires fsu et les
jeunes aussi les lycéens et valla et les
étudiants également les gilet jaune et
nous sommes en contact avec les députés
et donc on forme vraiment une un front
social qui est extrêmement important
contre ce projet de réforme des
retraites
on est mobilisée depuis le 5 décembre il
est hors de question on accepte ce coup
d'état de l'état donc voilà on est là ce
ce soit 60% la population de ce pays et
contre la réforme des retraites le
gouvernement n'écoute pas la population
le groupe la république en marche en a
rien à se déploie en disant que
les femmes par exemple vont y gagner
mais on a tout à perdre
on a tout à perdre et surtout retirer la
retraite de la sécurité sociale
on n'en veut pas et concernant
l'ambiance ici magali devant l'assemblée
nationale elle est somme toute festivin
même si un cordon des forces de l'ordre
c'est par les manifestants de l
assemblée les manifestants que l'on a
rencontrés ici ne sèche ne cesse de
chanter à des chansons bien sûr anti
gouvernement mais dans un bon esprit
ils nous ont confié qu'ils avaient
l'intention de rester une bonne partie
de la soirée
la soirée ne fait donc que est débuté
ici devant l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup pierre pour toutes ces
précisions